One day I was walking home from grocery shopping
with heaps of heavy bags and so I decided
to give some thought to which way home would
be the shortest.
Well, the shortest route would definitely
have been a straight diagonal path from the
shops to my house, but unfortunately no one
had made that path for me.
Instead there were only paths that went north-south
and east-west.
'Surely some of these paths are better than
others," I reasoned, "because the diagonal
line is the best, so routes which are almost
diagonal should be better than going all the
way around, right?"
At this point my brain started to hurt so
I forgot all this and just trudged back home
the regular way
When I got home though, I got interested in
the question again.
But I decided to make the problem a bit simpler.
I want to find out the shortest paths between
this corner and this corner of a square but
no diagonals are allowed, and the paths can
only go left or up.
This is the longest path from A to B, two
units long.
The would-be shortest path is the diagonal,
which by trusty Pythagoras is root 2 units
long.
Lets draw some other random path.
What's the total distance in the left direction?
Well, I guess its one unit.
And the distance in the up direction is 1
also.
Making the total distance 2, just like the
long way around The same thing is true for
all the paths.
I was completely wrong, there is no shortest
path because all those paths are exactly the
same length
To you this is probably like, yeah obviously.
For me this is still so surprising.
Let me explain.
The diagonal is the shortest route, but we
can draw one of our allowed paths that approximations
it.
You might not think this is a good approximation,
but I can make it better and better and better,
until your eyes couldn't even tell the difference.
In fact, couldn't I make the approximation
so good, someone walking on it couldn't even
tell they're not quite walking on a straight
line?
But then, they have to be able to tell because
no matter how great the approximation is,
these paths all have length 2 which is way
longer than root 2 so this way they'll end
up walking so much extra distance than if
they were actually on the diagonal.
That's the bit that really messes with my
mind.
Another weird bit is that in some ways the
sequence is a good approximation for the line.
If you know calculus or have seen last episode,
you know that if what I cared about was the
area underneath the diagonal instead of the
diagonal's length, this stair case shape has
area that gets closer and closer to the area
we want.
So we have this sequence of shapes that visually
approximate the line very well, and we know
it approximates its area very well.
And yet it's terrible at approximating the
line's length.
This is a really worrying example.
How do we know in advance when an approximation
is not good enough?
I really don't know.
So even though we all use approximation a
lot with out a second thought, even approximations
that look like they're really good can go
completely wrong.
Well, there are lots of places we go from
here because this whole thing brings up heaps
of questions.
One bit I'm really interested in is the fact
that the shape we were talking about is actually
a fractal.
Fractals in general are kind of the arch nememis
of Calculus, so we might take up the story
there next time.
See you then!